GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO A
SPECIAL DEMOCRATIC DEBATE
ADDITION OF TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
WE TOLD YOU IN THE PAST THAT
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTERS DON'T
SEEM TO HAVE MUCH OF A CHOICE
THIS YEAR.
THERE ARE AN AWFUL LOT OF
CANDIDATES IN THE RACE, BUT ALL
OF THEM SEEM TO HAVE IDENTICAL
FAR LEFT POSITIONS ON THE ISSUES
THAT MATTER.
YOU NAME IT.
UNTIL YESTERDAY, THAT WAS OUR
VIEW, AND THEN WE WATCHED LAST
NIGHT'S DEMOCRATIC DEBATE.
WE WILL HAVE TO REVISE THAT
ASSESSMENT.
IT TURNS OUT THAT NOT EVERYONE
IN THE FIELD IS A LUNATIC.
WE STAND CORRECTED ON THAT.
IN FACT, THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
SANE ONES.
UNFORTUNATELY, THEY ARE GETTING
CRUSHED.
WATCH, FOR EXAMPLE, WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN CONGRESSMAN RYAN
TRIED TO REMIND HIS DEMOCRATS
THAT MOST DEMOCRATS DON'T
SUPPORT OPEN BORDERS.
RYAN SUDDENLY BECAME THE MOST
UNPOPULAR KID AT THE PARTY.
WATCH.
>> NOW, IN THIS DISCUSSION, WE
TALKED ABOUT TAKING PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE AWAY FROM UNION
MEMBERS IN THE INDUSTRIAL
MIDWEST.
WE TALKED ABOUT DECRIMINALIZING
THE BORDER.
AND WE TALKED.
I QUITE FRANKLY, DON'T THINK
THAT THAT IS AN AGENDA THAT WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD ON AND WIN.
WE'VE GOT TO TALK ABOUT THE
WORKING CLASS ISSUES.
THE PEOPLE WHO TAKE A SHOWER
AFTER WORK WHO HAVEN'T HAD A
RAISE IN 30 YEARS.
IF WE FOCUS ON THAT, WE WILL WIN
THE ELECTION.
>> YOUR RESPONSE, SIR?
>> NOT A LOT OF APPLAUSE.
IN FACT, DEAD SILENCE.
IT TURNS THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
ROOM DIDN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WORKING CLASS ISSUES OR PEOPLE,
AS TIM RYAN PUT IT, WHO TAKE A
SHOWER AFTER WORK.
PROGRESSIVES WROTE THOSE WATERS
OFF AS DISGUSTING A LONG TIME
AGO.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY ARE
DEEPLY PRIVILEGED.
THAT GOES WITHOUT SAYING, THEY
COULD BE RACIST.
EVERY ONE OF THEM.
THEY HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM THE
EMERGING AL SHARPTON PRIVATE
EQUITY COALITION THAT DEFINES
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AS ELIZABETH WARREN AND
BERNIE SANDERS.
THE VERY IDEA THAT YOU HAVE TO
WIN POPULAR SUPPORT FOR YOUR
POLICIES SEEM TO ENRAGE THEM.
WARREN, ESPECIALLY.
AT ONE POINT, THEY ACCUSED A CNN
PERSON AS BEING A SECRET
REPUBLICAN.
FIRST TIME THAT HAS EVER
HAPPENED.
>> DO NOT SUPPORT MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
>> YOUR QUESTION IS A REPUBLICAN
TALKING POINT.
>> WHAT YOU WANT TO DO INSTEAD
IS FIND REPUBLICAN TALKING
POINTS OF A MADE UP PIECE OF
SOME OTHER PART AND SAY OH, WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE TO DO ANYTHIN
ANYTHING.
STOP USING REPUBLICAN TALKING
POINTS IN ORDER TO TALK WITH
EACH OTHER ABOUT HEALTH CARE.
SEE ONE THAT REALLY WAS THE
STORY OF THE WHOLE NIGHT.
ELIZABETH WORN JUMPING UP AND
DOWN AND BARKING AT ANYONE WHO
ASKS TOO MANY QUESTIONS.
NOT EVERYTHING ELIZABETH SAYS IS
WRONG.
WE ACTUALLY LIKE HER VIEWS ABOUT
MANUFACTURING AND TRADE FOR
EXAMPLE.
HOLY SMOKES, IS WARREN
UNBEARABLE IN A LOT OF WAYS.
NASTY AS.
WATCH HOW SHE TREATED JOHN
DELANEY, WHO IS ONE OF THE
NICEST MEN IN POLITICS.
>> I THINK DEMOCRATS WIN THE ONE
WE RUN ON REAL SOLUTIONS, NOT
IMPOSSIBLE PROMISES.
WHEN WE RUN ON THINGS THAT ARE
POSSIBLE, NOT FAIRY TALE
ECONOMICS.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY ANYBODY GOES
THROUGH ALL THE TROUBLE OF
RUNNING FOR THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES JUST TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE SHOULDN'T DO AND WHAT WE
CAN'T FIGHT FOR.
>> Tucker: SO, IF YOU ARE NOT
ARE READ IN THE FACE DISHONEST
DEMIGOD, LIKE WARREN THINKS YOU
ARE.
SHE TWISTED HIS POINTED TO
SOMETHING COMPLETELY
UNRECOGNIZABLE.
>> YOU A SAIN IMMIGRATION SS
>> YOU A SAIN IMMIGRATION SE
>> YOU A SAIN IMMIGRATION SM
NEEDS A SAIN LEADER.
>> LAWS MATTER, AND IT MATTERS.
WHO COME HERE SEEKING ASYLUM.
THAT IS NOT A CRIME.
>> Tucker: LAWS MATTER?
ELIZABETH WARREN, YES OF ALL
PEOPLE JUST SAID THAT.
AMAZINGLY, NOBODY IN THE ROOM
PUSHED BACK AGAINST HER SAYING
THAT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF WEAK MEN IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS
ACTUALLY.
A NORMAL CANDIDATE WOULD HAVE
ROASTED HER.
LAWS MATTER?
PLEASE.
ELIZABETH WARREN'S ENTIRE
IMMIGRATION PROGRAM IS BASED ON
THE FACT THAT LAWS DON'T MATTER
AT ALL.
IF LAWS MATTER, WE WOULDN'T HAVE
ILLEGAL ALIENS LIVING INSIDE OUR
BORDERS.
IF LAWS MATTERED, WE WANTED TO
HAVE SANCTUARY CITIES.
IF LAWS MATTERED, DEMOCRATS WHEN
IT BE SHARING LANGUAGE GUIDES
TELLING ILLEGALS HOW TO EVADE
ELIZABETH WARREN, CLAIMING THE